hey guys i got so many video requests
from some of you on how to improve
yourself
in different areas of your life for
example health
fitness
grooming
and style
but you know what your personality is a
lot more important than these outward
things
you know yeah
let's be honest here style fitness
grooming all of these things are very
important but your character is a lot
more important because usually guys go
and they're like oh man i need to wear
this shirt or that shoes or i need to
style my hair this way then people will
like me more but they forget people
focus a lot more on your personality
that's why they don't like you or why
they might like you
maya angelou said people will forget
what you said people will forget what
you did but people will never forget how
you made them feel
are you
self-aware do you have emotional
intelligence
do you know how you make people feel in
certain situations you know it's one of
the ugliest things when you see a guy
dressed in the best clothes with the
best style looking fit and healthy but
then he's not self-aware he doesn't even
realize that he is disrespectful
boastful and that he walks over people
you know that guy
don't be that guy
you know this is very old cool book
full of wisdom
it's a few thousand years old
and uh you know humans never change it's
still the same so the truth the wisdom
in that book is still the same today
and it says this for if anyone thinks he
is something when he is nothing he
deceives himself
do you know this book it is called the
bible
now how do you improve your
self-awareness i'm going to give you
five important tips that you can focus
on to be more self-aware number one
be honest with yourself brutally honest
you know a lot of people go through life
and they are in denial about a lot of
things including who they really are
edward literal said the easiest person
to deceive
is one's own self
you know i think a lot of people are
confused
when they think about
who they really are they confuse their
ideal self who they want to be with
their real self with the reality they
are not objectively honest with
themselves when it comes to their
weaknesses strengths emotions and their
characteristics
learn to examine yourself honestly you
need to learn what triggers you what
makes you happy what motivates you
what
makes it hard for you to talk to certain
people with what what personalities do
they have that clash with yours and what
might make you act in certain ways that
will cause conflict with other people
stephen covey said self-awareness is our
capacity to stand apart from ourselves
and examine our thinking our motives our
history our scripts
our actions and our habits and
tendencies
try to look at yourself objectively and
ask yourself this question
who am i
really
write down all your weaknesses and then
start to improve them here's a few
examples ask yourself do i really listen
to people when i talk to me
do i interrupt people when they speak
is it more important for me to always be
right in a disagreement even though the
relationship will take long-lasting
damage
do i get angry quickly do i let my
emotions control me or do i control my
emotions
do i really have good manners like
eating with my mouth closed or is it
possible that people will feel disgusted
when i talk to them with food in my
mouth do i always say thank you if
someone is trying to help me or do i
just forget because i don't care
do i just care about
what i say to people or
is the way i say things just as
important
do i really have good reasons for not
doing things or am i just lazy and i'm
just making excuses
and do i do things
to other people that i don't want to be
done to myself
now this list can go on and on and on
you can make your own list but you need
to be honest with yourself
that's the only way that you can
understand yourself better and to make
the appropriate changes in yourself
you know that old book
it says this the purpose in a man's
heart is like deep water but a man of
understanding will draw it out
do new things to understand yourself
better a good idea is to go for new
things new experiences to put yourself
in positions that you're not used to to
get out of that comfort zone and to
experience the unknown
why
well to get just know yourself and how
you will handle different situations
that you've never been in before
focus on things like how did i really
feel at that moment
how did i think how did i act in that
situation
if you always just stay in your comfort
zone
then you never change and you kind of
get stuck and you can't see yourself as
you really are anymore because you and
the situation that you're always in is
just so predictable so it means you
can't have a different perspective on
yourself anymore because you're just
stuck in your comfort zones
stuck in life
ask a good and honest friend
you might try to be objective when you
examine yourself
but to be honest you won't be able to
fully do it because we are all biased
and you won't look at yourself
objectively
and that is why you need a good and
honest friend because they can see the
things we say the things we do
from an outside perspective
they see the things about
us that we normally can't see ourselves
or even realize
you know the brutal honesty the truth
of a friend might hurt at times
but it is only the truth
that can set you free and a good friend
is someone who tells you the truth even
when you don't want to hear it because
it hurts
you know we as humans can only grow only
change if we truly become vulnerable to
really face the truth as it is about
ourselves
so ask a good honest friend to tell you
more about who you really are by the
things that you do that you are not
aware of
start to really care
if you don't really care about other
people you'll give little attention to
the way that you treat them you kind of
just act out of habit without pausing
and thinking about what you're actually
doing what you're actually saying and
how you're actually saying it to them
meaning you act without being self-aware
not because you can't be self-aware but
just because you're not focused on it
you're just focused on just acting out
of habit
warren buffett said chains of habit are
too light to be felt until they are too
heavy to be broken
force yourself to change
self-awareness is very important because
it is about ultimately knowing yourself
it is the key to unlocking yourself to
self-mastery it's about knowing yourself
better understanding your own flaws and
your faults and it's not about oh now
that i can see all my mistakes and all
the things that i do wrong oh
i'm i'm not worth anything
then you just sit in one place and you
kind of moan and you just said no
don't be like one of those people it's
not gonna help you at all it's about
identifying those things about yourself
taking responsibility for it and then
changing it for the better
self-awareness is ultimately knowing
yourself better to take a look at
yourself and
and see all right what do i need to
change here these things right i need to
change these and these things all right
i need to improve this area of my life
here stephen covey said in our personal
lives if we do not develop our own
self-awareness and become responsible
for first creations we empower other
people and circumstances to shape our
lives by default it is time to stop
making excuses to stop blaming other
people to stop blaming other situations
it's time to take a hard look in the
mirror and to take responsibility to
become self-aware
why because if you don't do it you'll
just you'll never grow
you'll be stuck in life
and remember life is short
so don't waste yours
if you want more self-improvement tips
start with communication watch these
videos here and i'll see you there
cheers guys